Vikings Rams this weekend Case Keenum
former Rams quarterback now the Vikings
quarterback big big win over the
Redskins threw for 300 yards four
touchdowns and it's a revenge time
against the Rams or at least that's
probably how they're playing this out
case joins us now case where are you
right now
well a Minnesota man in the recovery
room just just hanging out man wait what
are you recovering from well it
certainly is it doesn't take as much
time when you're not on the ground as
much but I definitely have my offensive
line to thank for that for sure
okay so you're not hurt no I just
hanging out just stopped on the way to
the film room so uh Doug do you know if
you're starting this Sunday I mean in my
own head for sure am that's that's uh
you know I've approached it that's how
I've answered it you know I don't know
how else to answer it you know and
that's that's all I have to you know
it's off to have to I have to approach
every week okay but how difficult is
that that like it feels like every week
it's you're playing you're auditioning
for your job at some point don't you
think you've earned the job you know
what it may feel that way to you but I
mean I feel like you know I feel like
I'm not I'm not auditioning for my job
you know ever I mean I feel like I've
had auditions for my job every day of my
life and so that's that's just how I
approach that's just normal for me you
know I know you guys you guys have your
job and you guys do do what you guys do
and talk and obviously those other other
media jackals and whoever it is and I'm
on your side case you might watch those
other guys the other guy okay yeah you
guys in the back row there's no Mick
love and you're a jackal hey hey McLovin
says you and you two are good friends
yeah we go way back right case yeah man
make love and poly man also fritz ease
the jackal in the back
okay there is fairness um how much when
you guys rehearse the end zone
celebrations when did you guys rehearse
that well you know we didn't rehearse
either of the two the duck-duck-goose we
just talked about it I think we all had
enough experience you know in our
childhood we we executed that pretty
well the Leapfrog you know it started
off a little dicey but but they managed
to finish it off and make it look good -
are you now do you have something
already planned this week you know I
don't know I did I actually missed out
on the Leapfrog they talked about in the
huddle and I don't know where I was I
don't know I guess I was in a different
huddle Wow
they went ahead and did it without me
and I'm on the sidelines you know
celebrate with some other teammates and
look over and they're having all the fun
in the end zone and I'm I'm actually
kind of kind of upset about it best team
you face so far this year's who oh
that's a tough one man
you know Pittsburgh obviously really
talented you know I think you know these
guys you know they were there they were
definitely a challenge Washington as far
as going back and forth you know
high-scoring back and forth game sorry
to say man there and when you play a
team early in the year they tend to to
be a lot different in the end of the
year I mean look at the Saints now so
and um you know it's uh it's a crazy
game is there revenge with the Rams this
weekend ah you know I don't know if I'd
say revenge I don't think that's the
right word you know I'm definitely
excited about playing these guys had
this one circle just you know just to
see everybody you know I know everybody
from the training room to the equipment
room to you know some of the some of the
coaches and you know players so I'm
excited to see those guys we're excited
to get out there I've been competing
against you know those guys on defense
of practice for the last three years so
I'm excited uh yeah get on the real
field but now they get to hit you case
the other killer Jersey on anymore so
they're probably more excited than I am
who is going to talk to you during the
game on that
you know I can already hear Michael
brokers voice right now just you know
hey case I don't know there's a bunch of
those guys
Aaron Donald's probably the guy that
will just you know just try to crush me
and not say a word but can you outrun
Aaron Donald I don't know if anybody can
man you don't think any quarterback can
outrun him I mean have you seen the dude
no I know he's unbelievable yeah he's
won a lot of awards and and I still
think he's underrated man he's a he's a
heck of a player I got a lot of respect
for him and and and that defense you
know being quarterback for that that
team it has helped me win a lot of games
so I I know I know firsthand what they
can do he's Case Keenum the Vikings
quarterback he believes he's starting
this weekend against the rim the
situation with Teddy Bridgewater you're
handling it you know like a pro you're
saying the right things it's an
unbelievable story that Teddy's even
back in uniform here how's that
relationship oh it's great man tell he's
awesome I'm I told somebody man I'm a
huge teddy bridgewater fan and that was
I started before I got here just
watching him on film and seeing him as a
player and when you get here and you
meet him you find out what kind of guy
he is what kind of teammate he is man
he's he's awesome and having him out
there I've come back from a knee injury
before and you know I know how emotional
and special it is to get back out there
I'm pumped for him I really am
and it helps that he he definitely
raises the the cool factor of our rooms
of our quarterback grown tremendously
can we crash at your house during the
Superbowl yeah come on man I'll just
I'll give you all the special friends
and family rate I like that it's so like
a Airbnb there yeah exactly man I got a
nice spot in my basement for McLovin
what do you have in your house that
would be cool because we need things we
have a man cave here we need some fun
things do you got you know a big TV is
not a big deal to us you got anything
fun
what do you have that's interesting here
you know we've moved around so much are
you renting
yeah we're renting man so I've you know
no I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
have to prepare something up for you
guys
nothing says party quite like a rental
exactly now if you guys aren't in the
Super Bowl are you staying in Minnesota
during Super Bowl week you know I don't
know one I don't want to really think
about that you know having plans you
know to do Super Bowl week besides
practice but it's right answer on those
tests in you that's all that's all I'm
doing just testing you all right you
paid oh yeah you passed all right well
good luck this weekend against the Rams
of course it's not a revenge it's just a
reunion McLovin would like to say
goodbye to go ahead make love and say
goodbye to Keith okay so we'll talk
later this afternoon I'll give you the
game plan for Sunday we're cool Wow okay
sounds good
Thank You Casey thanks guys appreciate
it that's Case Keenum mclubbe ins good
friend for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]